Hi! In this video, we'll look at how to use BurpSuite to evaluate inputs.
Once you have discovered functionality that's worth investigating further,
you can use a range of burp tools to evaluate the user controllable inputs,
and determine which inputs are most important to the application's function.
For example, do they impact the session or the state of the application?
Using BurpSuite, you can manually evaluate individual inputs, scan the inputs, or fuzz the inputs.
To follow along, you can use the lab SQL injection in WHERE clause,
allowing retrieval of hidden data in our Web Security Academy.
Before you start this tutorial, we recommend completing the following steps.
Set the test scope, map the target application,
and identify requests that you want to investigate further.
If you need help with any of these steps, we have separate tutorials for each of them.
First of all, we'll look at manually evaluating individual inputs.
To do this, send a request to BurpRepeater.
Go to the Repeater tab, and modify each input in turn.
You might want to remove the input completely, give the input an empty value,
or maybe insert a collaborator payload in the input by highlighting it,
and using right-click and selecting Insert collaborator payload.
Once you've made your changes, click Send.
Review the responses for any interesting behaviour, such as input reflections or differences in response times.
To identify subtle changes between responses, you can send the responses to BurpComparer.
In BurpComparer, you can select the two responses, click Words or Bytes to compare them,
and a new window will open with the results.
Compare our highlights any differences between the two responses.
Next, if you're using BurpSuite Professional, you can scan inputs to identify potential vulnerabilities,
which BurpScanner flags as issues.
To scan a single input, highlight the input.
You can do this from any message editor in Burp, for example from proxy HTTP history.
Right-click and select Scan Selected Insertion Point.
In the Scan Launcher window, click OK to start the scan using the default configuration.
If you'd like to scan multiple inputs at the same time, send the request to BurpIntruder.
On the Intruder Positions tab, add a payload position for each input you want to scan.
You do this by selecting the input and clicking Add.
Right-click the request and select Scan Defined Insertion Points.
Again, when the Scan Launcher opens, click OK to start the scan using the default configuration.
BurpScanner will audit the request using only the selected inputs.
To view any issues identified by these scans, go to the Tasks panel on the dashboard,
click View Details beside the task to open the Task Details dialog,
and switch to the Issue Activity tab.
This will contain a record of all the issues found during the scan.
Finally, we'll look at Fuzzing Input to identify potential vulnerabilities.
Highlight the input in the request, right-click, and select Send to Intruder.
Go to the Intruder Positions tab, and notice that because we highlighted it before sending it,
the input is automatically marked as a payload position.
Now, go to the Intruder Payloads tab, and under Payload Settings, add a list of fuzz strings.
If you're using BurpSuite Professional, open the Add from List drop-down menu,
and select one of the built-in fuzzing lists.
For example, Fuzzing Full, or in this case, Fuzzing SQL Injection.
Alternatively, you can add your own list.
Click Start Attack.
The attack starts in a new dialog.
BurpIntruder will send a request for each Puz payload.
When the attack is finished, study the responses to look for any interesting behaviour,
such as this request that solves the lab.
BurpIntruder is a good job.